PENNSYLVANIA'S OWN, MICHAEL
SMERCONISH IS ALSO WITH US THIS
MORNING.
WHAT ARE YOU MAKING OF WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN THESE NUMBERS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
AND WHAT THIS MEANS FOR
DEMOCRATS?
BECAUSE TYPICALLY THE WHITE
HOUSE IS BRACING FOR SOME
SERIOUS LOSSES HERE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WOULD
EXPECT GIVEN IT IS THE SITTING
PRESIDENT, HIS APPROVAL RATING
IS NOT GREAT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION THIS
MORNING?
>> ALL POLITICS BEING LOCAL, I
OF COURSE AM PHILLY BURB BASED.
YESTERDAY I WAS WITH YOU FROM
BUCKS COUNTY I SAID WELCOME TO
THE SWINGIEST OF COUNTIES IN A
SWING STATE.
WHAT'S AMAZING TO ME AS I SK
SCRUTINIZE THE NUMBERS IS HOW
JOHN FETTERMAN WAS ABLE TO
OUTPACE THOSE NUMBERS.
IN AN AREA YOU THOUGHT WOULD BE
ON THE MARGIN, HE BLEW ABOUT
MEHMET OZ IN BUCKS COUNTY
MONTGOMERY COUNTY.
I'M RELUCTANT TO GIVE THE NUMBER
ON CNN BECAUSE I CAN'T BELIEVE
HOW HIGH IT IS.
JOSH SHAPIRO IS A RESIDENT OF
MONTGOMERY COUNTY, SO THAT MAY
ACCOUNT FOR THE BOOST.
IF I WAS THE WHITE HOUSE I'D
LOOK AT THE PHILLY BURBS AND
TAKE A LESSON WITH HOW
SUCCESSFUL SHAPIRO AND FETTERMAN
WERE IN A FINAL ANALYST.
>> WHEN IT CAME TO MEHMET OZ, I
HEARD FROM A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
ABOUT HOW UPSET THEY WERE MEHMET
OZ WAS THE CANDIDATE BECAUSE
THEY THOUGHT DAVID McCORMICK,
THEY THOUGHT HE COULD HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN ON FETTERMAN.
WERE YOU SURPRISED AT ALL BY
FETTERMAN'S VICTORY?
>> I THINK ANOTHER ASPECT TO
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT IS WHILE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT ENDORSED
OZ, HE WAS REALLY NOT A FAVORITE
OF TRUMP VOTERS AND GROUPS IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
SO THEY SORT OF CAME ALONG,
RELUCTANTLY, TILL THE END AND
BACKED HIM TO THE HILT.
THERE WAS A LOT OF THOUGHT THAT
McCORMICK WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
COMPETITIVE.
>> DID THAT HAVE TO DO WITH THE
CRITICISM FROM THE FETTERMAN KA
CAMPAIGN, HE'S NOT REALLY FROM
HERE, DOESN'T LIVE HERE, WHEN HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT A STEELERS
GAME IN THE LAST FEW DAYS OF THE
RACE, THERE WAS NO STEELERS GAME
THAT WEEK.
>> YOUR POLLING AND RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT ISSUE ABOUT NOT
LIVING IN PENNSYLVANIA IS A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT ONE.
AND AS I KNOW MICHAEL AND OTHERS
HAVE SAID, IT'S NOT JUST NOT
LIVING IN PENNSYLVANIA, IT'S
LIVING IN NEW JERSEY, WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT MATTER.
>> AND NOT BEING A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE, RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT FETTERMAN AND HIS
HOODIES AND TATTOOS EXUDED FOR
SO MANY PEOPLE.
EVEN THE STROKE MADE HIM MORE
HUMAN.
I THINK VOTERS WERE EMPATHIC
WITH HIS STRUGGLES.
>> AND THE RISK HE TOOK
PARTICIPATING IN THE FINAL
DEBATE.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT TO BE
TAKEN FROM A POPULOUS DEMOCRAT
REACHING OUT TO WORKING CLASS
VOTERS, PLAYING INSIDE THE BASE
AND SOMEONE NOT LIVING IN A
STATE MOST OF THEIR LIFE, YOU
WOULD THINK THAT WOULD HURT.
AND THE DEAL THAT TROZ MADE WIT
TRUMP TO GET THIS.
REPUBLICANS NARROWLY ONE THE
SUBURBS NATIONALLY, THAT MAY BE
MORE OBVIOUS IN PLACES LIKE NEW
YORK THAN PENNSYLVANIA.
BUT ALSO THE GOVERNOR'S RACE,
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION GIVEN
MASTRIANO WAS SOMEONE THAT
QUESTIONED THE RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION LAST TIME.
>> AND HE TARGETED PHILADELPHIA
SAYING THE VOTE COUNT WAS
UNDERHANDED OR CORRUPT, WHICH,
OF COURSE, WAS A PAIR ERANOID
FANTASY.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS SHAPIRO'S CAMPAIGN AND
FETTERMAN'S CAMPAIGN WERE SO
DIFFERENT FROM ONE ANOTHER AND
HAD THE SAME GOAL, THAT WAS TO
BRING IN VOTERS OTHER THAN THEIR
DEMOCRATIC BASE.
WHETHER IT WAS SHAPIRO REACHING
OUT TO REPUBLICANS OR FETTERMAN
REACHING OUT TO THE WHITE COLLAR
WORKERS.
>> WE'VE SEEN THE POLITICS OF
DIVISION NARROWLY WIN VICTORIES.
IT WAS CAN THESE ELECTION
DENIERS WHO CAN WIN A PARTISAN
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY WITH DONALD
TRUMP'S ENDORSEMENT CAN THEY
CROSS OVER AND WIN AN ELECTION
IN A PURPLE STATE, THE ANSWER
TODAY SEEMS TO BE NO.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS WE
MOVE WEST IN THE KEY RACES.
>> LIKE WITH KARI LAKE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS A DRAG ON
THE REPUBLICAN VOTERS.